yeah welcome to yet another game against
tita or tetra it's a go for a Slav set
up someone requested the Marin or the
semi Slav so I'm trying for that but
he's not playing deform maybe going for
one of those funny setups where white
plays g4 castles long okay and not not
now okay yeah well I'm i played a six
which is probably not the greatest ever
move and this kind of setup hmm now we
can play free form okay
yeah something went wrong here I like to
play me five actually two to open up the
position but here in this concrete
position he can maybe take on d5 take on
e5 and even grab the pawn on d5 okay
that's some let's try it this way you
can always play yeah this or C 580 forms
both are both them viable you have to
take on you for a couple of times it's
just it's just very very uncomfortable
takes Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes Knight can click Knight f6 maybe
maybe this isn't so bad let's try it ah
maybe he's got 94 k didn't happen okay I
thought here and if he goes Quincy six
we should be seven now the Queen doesn't
have many squares so okay and here i
thought maybe take and play c5 instantly
to free the position yeah but it's not
it's not a mate the t5 might be the real
the real idea
should I play age 6 mmm it's not nice
I cannot d5 I can yeah this is not not
so great I think he can take on age 7
but at the end of all this i have i have
huge bishops yeah yeah but i'm not sure
i don't think this is so great yeah just
uh I overlooked this one this is a bit
embarrassing I need to take now and yeah
Wow
yeah very stupid no it's got just the
next report it was very completely
unnecessary I can just play age six and
nothing's nothing much happening okay
195 is an additional problem
the only 95 I can set up a trap Hiro
p895 Queen f2f it's it's it's okay it's
a trap mm-hmm okay
you should hear
or something else
I cannot take my can take f 2 this is
khalid and somehow don't don't realize
that the screen only four covers this no
move no move really
no good one at least I can play c5 maybe
I wanted to cover this but Roxy five how
many can be able piayed
no I'm threatening Bishop f2 finally it
took a while and it's not so clear what
is playing now actually takes take it
all don't see the big point okay so on
I'm better now but okay at the time even
have to ask collapsing J
my morning
19 seconds
yeah 19 seconds is not much
j
ah yeah what is stupid game what a
stupid game yeah I was hard to do any
comments if you play so badly as I'm
doing I mean you're just I'm just
support down then he blunders just one
point two pawns just donating everything
to give me a winning position and then I
didn't manage to win I mean I'm on 20
seconds of course but so yeah if six was
probably stupid but I wanted to prevent
the night moves here takes moves you too
everything's winning yeah now look abie
to hear from him this is yeah calm calm
wise the draw button it's a rookie torso
draw but i don't have f 12 seconds this
is of course blunders to root g 7 and 9
h 6 there are two made threats that i
cannot i cannot cover them both so yeah
I love it the real the real problem was
that I overlooked this especially for
moose otherwise I'm okay in this
position don't think but but the real
problem is here this position I can just
play a normal move I mean age six or
something don't think I should be in any
any danger maybe I am Queenie force an
issue something like this and if I go
age six
yeah if I go age six which I thought I
can always play this this this stuff
it's it's a ted shaky I don't know it's
very hard to tell this kind of stuff can
be em here this is this can be a
terrible for black or really good for
like I mean if he doesn't meet me I'll
get anything very concrete then I just
have two bishops out the better
structure but it looks it looks a bit
tricky for black yeah thanks for
watching